Big O-notation is also sometimes called Landau notation, named after
the German mathematician--Edmund Landau.
He didn't invent the notation, which was done several years before him
by another German mathematician called Paul Bachman, but he popularized it in the 20th century.
In a way, this is actually quite ironic that you should have popularized a notation that
contains so much approximation as big O-notation because Edmund Landau was actually known
as one of the most exact and pedantic mathematicians.
His goal was to be uncompromisingly rigorous.
In his lectures that he used to given, he even had an assistant who always attended his lectures
and was instructed to interrupt him if he even omitted the slightest detail.
It's interesting that he introduced a notation that omits all of the details.